j'avais encore un rendez vous au studio
15 avec jacques chancel le studio case
c'était le studio du grand échiquier
oui alors je suis partagé parce que il y
a d'abord un grand bonheur de me
retrouver ici où je suis de passage
et puis une tristesse alors le bonheur
du nord c'est parce que ma voiture elle
est venue toute seule elle rejoignait sa
maison notre maison et puis à tristesse
lorsque je vois tout ne régit toutes nos
implantations tous nos rendez vous là où
ça se passe et qui sont complètement
massacré parce qu'il paraît qu'on va
faire d'ici autre chose et moi j'avais
toujours rêvé ici d'un musée soit et le
grand musée de la télévision on ne va
pas refaire l'histoire
et c'est vrai qu'au dans nos vingt
années eh bien j'ai passé ici à peu près
dix jours chaque mois mais dix jours
complets avec des équipes on était et je
crois que le mot est important tous
ensemble et où chaque émission était
faite en direct en plus de chic et
c'était quand même particulier ça durait
trois heures 3h30 4h celui de la comédie
française a duré cinq heures et demie et
tout cela dans le cadre du direct
lorsque je regarde je peux enlever ça
parce qu'il fait chaud a fait chaud
comme autrefois
aussi choquant 3 way alors lorsque
lorsque je revois le 15 parce que bon le
cacd laurenti chic et bien côté c'est le
13 c'est jean christophe averty un peu
plus loin ses biceps
là où travailler les carpentier et puis
je me souviens très bien des studios
étaient buval ou été santelli où étaient
lorenzi c'était vraiment toute une
famille et lorsque je regarde le quinze
de plus près immédiatement toute la
mémoire revient j'ai l'impression que
j'ai ri a quitté alors qu'il ya des
années que je ne suis plus revenu ici
rien au programme
ce studio qui doit faire je crois 700 m²
il y avait là bas dans le coin leurs
pièces fabriquées sans tarder
il y avait le coeur il y avait le public
boude et était là à 5 ou de changer et
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on regarde tout ce
plafond de lumière c'était quelque chose
de particulier ça n'est pas de la
nostalgie
on n'a aucune nostalgie parce que la
télévision faisceau son bon bout de
chemin jour dire que les choses changent
et c'est tout à fait naturel
mais il y avait une force d'abord la
force de cette maison notre maison
la force du bonheur de faire des choses
ensemble et puis aussi la force du
direct ou le playback à ce moment là
n'avait véritablement aucune importance
c'est à dire c'était le temps où on ne
trichez pas